c'est le coeur du château de versailles
la galerie des glaces un lieu symbolique
choisie par le président du conseil
français georges clemenceau pour la
signature du traité de versailles le 28
juin 1919
quand on se rend compte que des le sa
construction elle est achevée en 784 la
galerie des glaces semble cristalliser
dans son décor dans son espace
les relations entre la france et l'
empire le saint empire romain germanique
donc l'allemagne par les représentations
à la voûte qui sont qui marque les
victoires des armées françaises sur les
armes et de l' empire l'organisation de
la cérémonie et fait effectivement pour
mettre en valeur la galerie des glaces
ce lieu symbolique la délégation
allemande arrive la dernière dans la
galerie à 3 heures de l'après midi
toutes les autres délégations que les
aux délégués sont arrivés et c'est à ce
moment là que la cérémonie peut
commencer c'est que les morceaux qui
ouvre la cérémonie en invitant les
plénipotentiaires allemands a signé les
premiers 27 pays alliés sont représentés
par leurs délégués chacun leur tour ils
vont signer le traité sur ce bureau
disposé au milieu de la galerie des
glaces
ce bureau se trouvait dans les
collections de versailles au moment de
la signature
ils avaient été déposés en 1914 shot
versailles il était au palais de
compiègne au 19e siècle dans le salon et
l'impératrice eugénie
il arrive à versailles au début du
conflit et finalement c'est lui qui est
choisi comme beaux meubles bel exemple
d'un beau bureau pour cette cérémonie la
signature et le vomi nationale il place
également un fauteuil qui provient de la
salle des fêtes du palais de l'elysée
c'était un porte plume en or sur lequel
est écrit le mot pacs en émail en émail
blanc sur fond de rameau d'olivier
c'est le monde entier finalement qui
étaient présents à versailles et tous
les continents ont apposé leur signature
sur ce traité et finalement ils vont
réussir à briser les barrières de
protection étaient mises et envahir tout
l'espace pour aller féliciter
congratuler le président wilson david
lloyd george george clémenceau donc dans
une grand
aura de félicitations et de soulagement
à l'issue de cette signature
l'original du traité de versailles a été
détruit par les nazis durant la seconde
guerre mondiale le seul reflet de
l'histoire réside dans un numéro spécial
de l'illustration publié le 6 septembre
1919 avec la reproduction de ce document